this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing all
in one platform
through the link in the description
below more on them in a bit
on any list of the greatest american
novels there's one book you can
guarantee
will be near the top the grey gatsby
isn't just an acknowledged masterpiece
it's one of the most influential things
ever written its descriptions of wild
jazz parties
bootlegging millionaires and the
beautiful and damned of new york has
become
shorthand for the entire roaring
twenties yeah while gatsby continues to
exert a powerful hold over american
culture
knowledge of its author has faded almost
to the point of obscurity
and that's a pity because the life of f
scott fitzgerald is almost as
fascinating
as his most famous creation born to an
upper middle class family on a perpetual
downward slide
fitzgerald was a man tormented by his
failings
in his eyes he was never rich enough
tough enough manly enough
failings he tried to hide behind lavish
parties heavy drinking and
friendships with macho men like ernst
hemingway
yet while fitzgerald would never be able
to escape his sense of failure that
feeling would propel him to create
some of the greatest prose in american
history
it's a truism that everything comes down
to perspective
you might be poor useless and alone but
if you're used to being poor
useless alone and on fire then i mean
things don't look so bad on the other
hand you might be from a connected
family go to private schools mix with
the beautiful and the rich and
still feel like you're a miserable
failure it's in this latter category
that f scott fitzgerald fell born
francis scott fitzgerald on september
24th
1896 in saint paul minnesota fitzgerald
was the only son of an upper middle
class family desperately trying to cling
on
to that upper part his father edward was
a failed store owner turned salesman who
always seemed to be
one wrong step away from getting fired
while his mother molly although
now independently wealthy came from a
blue collar irish background
and since it's practically a legal
requirement for fitzgerald biographies
to mention this
we should note that the boy was named
after a famous distant cousin
francis scott key who wrote the star
spangled banner that trivia out of the
way fitzgerald spent most of his young
life between saint paul
and new york state as edward's job
forced the family to move
although they always lived among the
well-off fitzgerald was acutely aware
from an early age that he didn't quite
belong
his father's income was too precarious
his mother's background
to immigrant working class although he
would have seemed eye-wateringly wealthy
to most americans as a boy fitzgerald
always had the sense that
his family were interlopers in this rich
world
it was a sense that only increased when
in 1908 edward finally lost his job
for a 12 year old boy it was like
armageddon dear god
fitzgerald later said as he prayed
please don't let us go to the poor house
it was an easy request for the almighty
to grant molly still had her family's
money there were still relatives who
could pay for the boy to keep attending
his private schools but when you're 12
you don't realize how lucky you are you
just hear the other kids joking about
your deadbeat dad
see their expensive lives and feel like
an outcast
it would be this sense of always having
one foot inside and one outside the
world of the rich that
would one day drive fitzgerald's best
writing but while he
may have felt financially isolated
socially he was doing just fine
as a teen fitzgerald was relatively
handsome and charming to a fault
deadly dad or no deadbeat dad he still
got invited to parties
he still made out with pretty girls he
even managed to get into princeton in
1913 despite failing the admissions test
all his childhood molly had tried to
make up for their family standing by
telling her boy he was destined for
important things
now fate just seemed to be agreeing with
her the perfect environment for a social
butterfly
princeton saw fitzgerald at what he
considered his best
he joined the prestigious drama group
the triangle club he wrote witty
sketches for the campus magazine
skipped class to attend literary parties
it was like fitzgerald was
play acting his dream of what being
wealthy must be like
a dream where you could flunk all of
your studies and just still coast by
on your charm sadly it really was just a
dream towards the end of his time at
princeton
fitzgerald fell in love with januvra
king an obscenely rich obscenely pretty
socialite but the relationship soon fell
apart during a visit to king's home in
lake forest fitzgerald overheard her
casually declare
poor boys shouldn't think of marrying
rich girls
for someone as obsessed with status as
fitzgerald this comment
was like all his nightmares coming true
like being
uncovered for the phony that he felt he
was it was a feeling he'd never recover
from
it wasn't just where love was concerned
that fitzgerald's dreams were beginning
to crumble
in 1917 it was clear he was about to
flunk college no matter how popular he
was
so he decided to jump before he was
pushed that year fitzgerald walked away
from princeton leaving behind the
glittering wealthy life had chased for
so long for
a life of hardship and adventure and
life in the army
back in april the us had declared war on
germany now as 1918 approached huge
numbers of american troops were being
sent towards the western front among
their number
hoped to be f scott fitzgerald in the
last weeks before he was shipped to his
training camp the princeton dropout
wrote letters to his family declaring
that
he was certain he would die in europe as
the clock ticked down he
seems to have gone from merely telling
people this to actually believing it
actually believing he might die his
literary dreams unfulfilled
for the next few weeks anyone at the
officers club in new york might have
noticed a short handsome boy
hunched over a typewriter furiously
pounding the keys
he was desperate to get something
written before his death the result was
the romantic egotist a barely disguised
autobiographical take on fitzgerald's
time at princeton
it showed incredible promise so much so
that the publisher he sent it to
scribners told him in the rejection
letter that they would eagerly read
anything he sent in the future but a
future
was something fitzgerald was no longer
sure he had in early 1918 he was
shipped for training near montgomery
alabama since getting new recruits
combat ready was time intensive
fitzgerald would stay in the south for
most of the year and that was fortunate
because it gave him the chance to meet
zelda ser the daughter of a state
supreme court judge zelda possessed just
about every quality fitzgerald thought
was lacking in himself
she was wealthy confident unafraid of
what people thought she was also a party
girl par
excellence able to drink even the
hard-drinking fitzgerald under the table
the pair met in july by september
fitzgerald was writing in his diary the
short yet
oh so loaded sentence fell in love
thankfully he wouldn't have to test that
love in the nightmare of war
in november 1918 before fitzgerald could
be deployed the central powers collapsed
ending world war one
suddenly the young man was free to leave
the army to make a living
to marry his girl he headed to new york
city determined to land a plum job as a
journalist to make enough money to
impress zelda
instead fitzgerald found himself mere
months later working his ass off at an
advertising agency for a pittance his
one success in this period
writing the tagline for a laundry in
muscatine iowa
we keep you clean in muscatine not
exactly so we beat on votes against the
current
born back ceaselessly into the past is
it
at the same time as he was spending his
waking hours rhyming words with
muscatine
fitzgerald was simultaneously failing to
become a writer
in the whole of 1919 he sold only a
single short story
that made him 30 bucks as his
professional life loundered so did his
love life that year fitzgerald proposed
to zelda
only to be declined terrified he was
losing yet another rich girl he decided
to gamble everything on that encouraging
rejection letter from scribners
at the end of the year fitzgerald quit
his job got drunk for three days
straight and then left nyc for saint
paul
there he loaded his typewriter sat down
and furiously began rewriting
the romantic egotist it was a dumb hope
the sort of pathetic dream every failed
writer has that this time
with this rewrite they'll unleash his
hidden masterpiece
in fitzgerald's case it also happened to
be true now if you're ready to unleash
your hidden masterpiece then you're
going to need a little help from our
friends over at squarespace
you know what's great about the summer
vacation time off a little bit of
r and r it's the perfect time to be
lying on the beach or in the park
daydream about that next project that
you want to start fortunately
squarespace gives you
every possible tool you might want to
make your dream into a reality whether
it's a small business
a sports blog creative portfolio or just
a page of dank memes
it doesn't matter if you can dream it
you can build it with squarespace
are you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website should look like
bam use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person you've got lots of
opinions and
ideas about what exactly your site
should look like squarespace gives you
all the customization options you could
ever want with no updates
no patches no technical bs to worry
about once you're done
setting up your website tinkering with
the design if you're so inclined or
maybe just playing with the colors there
are so many extra features that
squarespace provides
that your website can thrive email
campaigns patronage portals
social integrations member only areas
analytics commercial options 24 7
customer support
everything you need is in one place so
when you're ready to get started on that
next project of yours big or small if it
involves a website it's got to be with
squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch your new site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics
to save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain
and let's get back to today's video
if you were a literature fan in the
1920s there would be only one
f scott fitzgerald book you were raving
about a book that defined the entire
jazz age
and its name wasn't the great gatsby
this side of paradise was the novel that
turned fitzgerald into a superstar
broadly its plot is no different from a
gazillion other coming-of-age novels but
in its specifics
it was a revelation this was the book
that first brought the roaring twenties
to popular imagination
a book that did for flapper girls and
jazz artists what human traffic did for
pill popping brits in 1999. the way the
characters acted the way they dressed
talked and experienced life were all
real all parts of what the new
generation was experiencing as they
shrugged off their parents values
published on march 26 1920 it turned
fitzgerald overnight
into the voice of his generation just 23
he was suddenly wealthy
fated and adored by readers and critics
alike
just a week after the book debuted
fitzgerald tied the knot with zelda no
longer was he the poor boy standing
outside the circles of the rich
looking helplessly in for the first time
in his life
fitzgerald was the rich one you can
probably guess
how the future great gatsby author dealt
with becoming famous
by partying like he was starring in the
baz
lehrman film of his own life in the
first half of the 1920s the fitzgerald
spent recklessly through bashes and
of course drank like a pair of alcoholic
fishes
with paradise a success fitzgerald was
suddenly in demand from
well-paying short story magazine
allowing him to top up his income at a
moment's notice
but even in these early days there were
already signs of
the trouble ahead fitzgerald was
spending like an italian government
throwing out way more money than he had
coming in forcing him to secure loans
against future writing projects
that was all fine so long as he
eventually wrote those books but
if he were to i don't know maybe get
writer's block one day
well yes that was absolutely
foreshadowing in late 1921 zelda gave
birth to their daughter scotty and the
family moved to the wealthy long island
enclave of great neck
there among the high-flying financiers
silent movie stars and other literary
celebrities
they lived out a grander vision of
fitzgerald's princeton days
it was a vision that would power his
next novel 1922's the beautiful and the
damned was a satire on the jazz age
fitzgerald was meant to speak for
a novel about excess and lusting after
wealth
today it's also considered his worst
book flawed work that just about gets a
pass
thanks to his command of language still
it was good enough to keep the couple in
the public eye and
they continued to lead their charmed
lives lives as charmed as
those of the princeton rich fitzgerald
had once obsessed over yet even as he
was living it there must have been
something about this life that bothered
him
around 1923 fitzgerald began sketching
ideas for a new novel one that would
expose the raw
emptiness of greatneck's social bubble
even
as he reveled in it but it wouldn't be
possible to write while still living
in this fine house still drinking these
fine cocktails still partying
with these powerful people back in 1921
the fitzgeralds had briefly decamped to
europe only to return when
zelda fell pregnant now the
war-shattered continent was looking
less like another venue for partying and
more like the perfect escape
in 1924 the couple made their move that
year america's hottest literary
superstar arrived on the french riviera
ready to write his masterpiece it was on
this sun-drenched coast overlooking the
blue waters
of the mediterranean that the great
gatsby would soon be born
the story of a curious midwesterner who
moves to long island and settles next to
the super-rich super mysterious
jay gatsby the great gatsby is one of
those novels that
everyone knows it's also one of those
novels that manages to cram impossible
amounts
into a tiny word count on its surface
it's about gatsby's longing for the rich
girl that he can never have and
the american elites who'll always reject
him no matter how much money he makes
but it's also a book about the usa's
hidden class system about the power
and limits of the american dream about
the emptiness of gatsby's life and
the dark side of the jazz age in short
it's a great with a capital g
type book something in which you can
find almost anything
but that's not how people saw it at the
time when gatsby hit the shelves in 1925
most reviewers were flummoxed
fitzgerald's latest a dud ran one
infamous headline while other critics at
least acknowledged the book's lyricism
they still felt the story of the
bootlegger gatsby was too simple too
tawdry to earn the appellation great
still the novel did have its fans
especially in artistic and bohemian
circles
and one of those fans would soon become
fitzgerald's greatest frenemy ernest
hemingway was a man who almost never had
a good word to say about any
contemporary writing
except his own in 1925 he was still a
lonely journalist living in paris and
working on his first real novel when
he began to hear about this famous
writer in town fitzgerald too had heard
of hemingway both back down on the
riviera and
after he and zelda moved to paris the
two finally met one fine april day at
the dingo bar
about two weeks after gatsby was
published it was the beginning of
literature's greatest bromance
and rivalry as with zelda fitzgerald
seemed to see something in hemingway
that he lacked in himself boundless
confidence physical strength and
a stack of stories from his war years
for his part hemingway having read
gatsby seemed to think fitzgerald was
just about the only other american
writer worth a damn
it probably helped that they were both
capable of putting away tremendous
quantities of alcohol
a mutual interest that defined their
friendship but it was a friendship
that would benefit one half more than
the other with his connections
fitzgerald was able to help papa get the
sun also rises published at
scribner's promoting hemingway's
literary career with more enthusiasm
than his own he also lent the younger
man money to rush home when his father's
health collapse loaned him his riviera
villa when his sick son needed to
recuperate
for his part hemingway openly admired
fitzgerald's talent telling him to
have more confidence in his abilities
but he was also something of a
massive douche towards him never once
like being in another man's shadow
hemingway belittled fitzgerald behind
his back spreading rumors that the
gatsby author was a pansy
he also openly hated zelda and would
later mercilessly eviscerate both of
them in print
hemingway's posthumous account of his
time in paris a movable feast payne's
fitzgerald's
feet xenophobic perpetually wasted and
scared his penis as too small to satisfy
women
i mean why stick the knife in when you
could just cut out his whole damn heart
hemingway
despite its dark side the two men's
friendship would keep up for several
years
shaping their careers but while
hemingway's career was destined to spend
the following decades reaching ever
greater heights
fitzgerald's was almost already over in
just a few short years
he was going to transition from voice of
his generation
to forgotten cracked up penniless
alcoholic
[Music]
by the time scott and zelda quit paris
and returned to the riviera their
relationship had settled into a state of
extreme dysfunction
the two were arguing constantly proper
screaming arguments that would end with
zelda grabbing her things and leaving
vowing never to return only to come back
that same night
the more they argued the more fitzgerald
drang until it became clear he wasn't a
party animal so much as a full-blown
alcoholic
while there's a romantic myth attached
to wright as an alcohol the reality of
fitzgerald was that his addiction
was devastating he began to suffer
writer's block unable to work on his
follow-up novel to gatsby
desperate to get something on the page
he resorted to stealing passages from
zelda's diary while recent scholarship
has disproved the theory that fitzgerald
was essentially passing off zelda's work
as his own
seriously zelda wrote no more gatsby
than dan brown wrote infinite jest it
was still
a crappy thing to do but as bad as
things were getting for fitzgerald they
were getting worse for zelda
throughout her life zelda had struggled
with mental illness although she was
diagnosed with schizophrenia
a modern psychiatrist would probably
label her bipolar
she certainly had the dizzying highs and
the devastating lows
starting around 1929 those lows got even
lower
after a brief stint back in america the
couple had returned to france where
zelda began to exhibit extreme obsessive
behavior
especially around her ballet lessons
while this might
sound somewhat harmless it did mask a
serious problem
that year zelda suffered a first major
breakdown a collapse that led to her
being placed in an institution
at the same time fitzgerald's physical
health gave out the latest effect of his
alcoholism
it's possible that the couple could have
ridden out the twin crises
had it not been for a third crash this
time one that would be heard around the
world
the wall street crash in october 1929
heralded the dawn of the great
depression it also threw into sharp
relief just how much money fitzgerald
had borrowed against future books
books he was now incapable of writing
just as zelda's medical bills were
starting to mount the fitzgeralds
abandoned europe for good in 1931.
at the time zelda seemed to be
recovering but another breakdown the
following year would
effectively end any semblance of a
normal life zelda would spend the rest
of her life in institutions eventually
dying in one in 1948
but not before she and fitzgerald had
another massive bust-up
in hospitals zelda began writing her own
novel save me the waltz about
her experience suffering a breakdown
when he realized what she was doing
fitzgerald freaked out about zelda using
the same material he'd already stolen
from
her diary they argued he tried to bury
her calling her a third-rate writer
she fought to tell a story although
scott finally relented the decision made
no one happy when waltz was published it
bombed
reviews were savage although it wouldn't
be fair to call zelda third-rate she
certainly was susceptible to overwriting
just check this random sentence from her
book the moon on the windowpanes
careens to the garden and ripples the
succulent exhalations of the earth
like a silver paddle you can almost hear
the
literary professors sharpening their
knives not that fitzgerald's take on
zelda's mental health issues fared much
better
when tender as the night came out in
1934 it wasn't so much released as
it stumbled out of the paddock wobbled
around a bit and then keeled over and
died of anthrax today the book
is considered one of his best but in
1934 no one wanted to read a book
about rich people problems in the wake
of tenders the night's commercial
failure fitzgerald fell apart not yet 40
he was washed up and forgotten a relic
of a frivolous age depression era
america
would rather forget it's an opinion that
wouldn't change until long
after he was dead
shortly after f scott fitzgerald's 40th
birthday residents at a wellness retreat
in asheville were
startled by the sound of a gunshot when
staff ran to check they found the once
famous rider slumped over
and a bullet hole in the wall behind him
no one knows if fitzgerald tried to
finish it all in that hotel room or if
the gun going off really
was the accident he claimed it was what
we do know is that that dark moment
seems to have been the lowest point
fitzgerald ever reached it was the
moment he decided things had to change
a few months later he visited zelda to
say goodbye and then the author of the
great gatsby packed his things and
headed west
out in the blazing sun of the golden
state fitzgerald seemed to have found a
way to
shake off his depression he landed a
celeried gig as a screenwriter at mgm
where he didn't exactly become rich but
he made enough to pay off both his debts
and zelda's medical bills
it was to be honest hack work the sort
of uncredited script doctoring even the
right monkeys biographics probably
couldn't manage but it was steady work
regular stable work where you needed to
be somewhere
at the same time each day and couldn't
roll in blitzed on martinis no matter
how many novels you'd written in short
it was exactly what fitzgerald needed
out there in california he began to lay
off the source by 1939
he was almost sober he began seeing the
gossip columnist sheila graham started
writing again
not the type of writing he did at mgm
but serious literary writing
by 1940 he was almost halfway through a
new book called the last tycoon it was
shaping up to be one of his best perhaps
his best ever
sadly we'll never know if it could have
lived up to expectations
just before christmas 1940 f scott
fitzgerald suffered a massive heart
attack likely a result of his
decades of alcoholism he clung on in
hospital for a while
before finally slipping away on december
21st he was 44.
at the moment he died fitzgerald was
almost forgotten as a writer
obituaries remembered him as a one-hit
wonder that wonder kid who'd
written the epoch defining this side of
paradise
before drifting off into a haze of gin
fumes
compared to his old buddy ernest
hemingway it seemed like fitzgerald's
name would
soon fade completely but posterity was
about to throw
his work a lifeline in the middle of
world war ii the us army became worried
about conscripted men
suffering boredom on base they had on
the idea of armed services edition
paperbacks cheap books distributed for
free to any soldier who wanted them
hundreds of titles were selected
designed to cater to every taste
some inevitably wound up being more
popular than others among the most
popular
was the great gatsby for whatever reason
gatsby struck a chord with
the enlisted men who read it by the time
the war ended it had
hundreds of thousands of new fans
clamoring for more from its author
it was the start of a fitzgerald revival
by the 1960s gatsby would have been
reevaluated as a masterpiece fast
forward to the here and now and it's a
serious contender
for the greatest novel of all time today
gatsby is what we think of when we think
of f scott fitzgerald all those images
of jazz age decadence filtered through
the lens of
leonardo dicaprio or robert redford's
performance
in some ways this is a bit of a shame to
see such a fascinating life reduced to
merely the author name
on an iconic book all the troubles and
triumphs of
its owner now nearly forgotten on the
other hand it ensures fitzgerald's work
will continue to be known for
as long as there are readers who care
about good writing who want to
understand the
mindset of an entire age fitzgerald's
own life may have been subsumed by
creation but as we've hopefully
demonstrated today
it was a life as strange as petty and as
brilliant
as that of jay gatsby himself so i
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also
please do check out fantastic sponsors
squarespace there's a link to them below
and thank you for watching
[Music]
you